هدنه هشه لا اثر لها على الارض فاصوات
اطلاق النيران ودوي الانفجارات سمعت
باستمرار في مناطق مختلفه من الخرطوم
وتحديدا حول مقر الجيش والقصر الجمهوري
سلسله الادانات بمسؤوليه خرقها لا زالت
متبادله بين الاطراف المتنازعه ليقذف كل
منهم كره الاتهام في ملعب الاخر رغم
الجهود الامميه والدوليه المكثفه
الطرفان المتقاتلان لا يعطيان الانطباع
بانهما يريدان وساطه من اجل السلام بينهما
على الفور فكنت افعله في اليومين الماضيين
هو محاوله التوسط في توقف انساني لمده
ثلاث ساعات في اليوم
الجيش السوداني نفى مسؤوليه عن الهدنه
واكد في بيان له ان قوات الدعم السريع لم
تلتزم بها وهاجمت مواقع استراتيجيه من
محيط المطار ومبنى القياده العامه
السيطره على هذه المواقع تعد انتصارا
كبيرا قد يحسم بقيه المعارك في المواقع
الاخرى وفقا لخبراء
وبسبب اهميتها القصوى حصن الجيش مركز
القياده من الجهتين الشماليه والغربيه لكن
المعارك اشتدت في الجهتين الجنوبيه
والشرقيه المقابلتين لمطار الخرطوم
قوات الدعم السريع وجهت بدورها ايضا
اتهامات مماثله لقوات الجيش بمخالفه
للقانون الدولي الانساني وقواعد الاشتباك
وخرق الهدنه المتفق عليها بوساطه دوليه
وتبقى الاتهامات متبادله وسط تضارب كبير
في الروايات بين الجانبين سلطان العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات